Peggy 18  let me tell you the story  superdad the  hero of / Garen he used to be a regular  dad in one day there was an accident but  super dad wasn't killed  he got superpowers instead no bullet can  hurt him now and bad guys don't stand a  chance  last night super dad defeated dr. Zed  but his work is not done yet they're  still able man in the garden and someone  has to take care of them  each night I'm back I see you sleeping  soundly and I envy you because in your  world of superheroes  there's only good and evil black and  white - made up of all kinds of shades  there are no signs to show you the right  way so you have to trust your guts and  hope that you've done the right thing  whatever that means now